okay new game um playing a Grand Master
here el Presidente located in key
burrata okay let's check the names God
doesn't have a name in here but you
gotta just means he's playing the strong
open in the burrata so funny he's
suddenly not located them usually can we
get a double fianchetto him and his
opted for this see 526 set up yeah I
always forget how this is played okay
yes a fairly fairly solid second set up
for black a 525
yeah of course some my centers under
under some pressure here
hmm
ok let's let's take it first
yeah I need to relieve some pressure
here
yeah this line it shows us some fairly
fairly good for black so almost an
instant equalizer yeah yeah this is some
very logical don't want to allow him to
take him here d force some wood week
then maybe yeah she'll play c5 is also
not great but better I think then let
him intake here defaults very weak then
of course black has no problems here
whatsoever
b6 for instance would be a logical move
now attacking pornsharia some also i
cannot really am protect c5 so I am
ready to take him and then he just got
them some goop some fine pressure unity
for like it's better now it's also got
a5 a4 ideas I've I just got the weaker
weaker pawn structure okay this is some
almost always useful and maybe it uses
some kind of slide weakness maybe yeah
it's an uncomfortable position simple as
that
maybe on a form Bishop e3 trying to get
something on it seven and maybe play
Bishop c5 yeah he prevented this
now I don't want to play three button
before what would have been a problem
anyway we of course you can regroup here
maybe try to get this Bishop to b5 yeah
black is more comfortable no question I
hope it's not so easy to crack down on
them yeah okay maybe tries to invade
here maybe get some activity
the exchanges now I can take with the
night and at least i got some selective
night position here i avoided this may
be the ideas roxy one yeah more it's an
idea maybe I can play Knight g5 now
prevent the worst here or couldn't be
three maybe queen bee three going for
rugby 7 i'm not quite sure about this
position it should be worse for me but
it's not not completely clear cats I've
got some activity as well here on f7 and
maybe 95 this Bishop basis I was wrong
look rook a fruit hit f1 could be an
issue here maybe that's a trick here but
ok is back ranked this week simply you
cannot do whatever you please the CM
this this configuration is a problem for
black maybe I'm even even good here not
sure he didn't he didn't play this
didn't play this some in an optimal
fashion I'm pretty sure
so it's very difficult this is
surprising not quite sure what is doing
the exchanges I got this the other look
on the seventh as well
quite difficult difficult position
who
not quite sure what's the idea I
couldn't see one maybe Quincy man Quincy
one
I've ff3 is still three
well I hope it doesn't have a simple may
gio something our h1 the camp tire gauge
one maybe but this still isn't a maid I
think
nine inch for so the time also
coo cachoo Koscheck medium John struck
me how this was difficult I'm pretty
sure I've somehow I got out of this and
I cannot I don't think this should be
way way back to bed for me at all maybe
I'm assessing this wrong but this cannot
be bad for white almost impossible with
black code black sking almost almost
made here yeah comfort suggests rugby
age yeah Ruby eight maybe assesses is it
at about equal yeah maybe equal but I
shouldn't I shouldn't really lose and
now he wants to take on c4 with was
almost a winning advantage yeah I was
briefly thinking about this but well I
didn't have much time and this losses
yeah yeah I didn't take this into
account radium I didn't have hadn't have
enough time to to really figure out this
position yeah this the opening result
was just just just a little bit too bad
and I spent too much time you're
interesting finish though ok next one